hey what's up guys my name is achono and
i am excited
it's been about a year since we had that
first glance at unreal engine 5
and here we are with 15 minutes of
unreal engine 5
early access and in fact the source code
for this is now available this new
technology that we've seen has been
exciting for a number of different
industries for a number of different
reasons for me
as a game engine developer this has been
something that i've been looking forward
to seeing ever since we saw that first
look
and to be honest it's been out for like
what time is it it's been out for like
15 hours at this point so i
and i still haven't seen any of this
because i've just been waiting to
finally get the chance to sit down
and record this video so for those of
you who have no idea what's going on
unreal engine is a game engine that i'm
sure a lot of people subscribe to my
channel have heard of they've been
working on
unreal engine 5 which is the next kind
of big release of their technology
and early access is finally here and
available to try out and this is a video
explaining what that is if you're new to
this channel then
welcome i am a game engine developer i
used to work at ea
on various game engines and then i quit
to start working on my own game engine
which is called hazel and that is what
i'm currently doing as well as making
educational youtube videos on the topic
of programming and game engine
development
i'll have some interesting videos linked
down there if you want more information
but anyway without further ado honestly
let's just dive in and take a look at
this video
because i i'm beyond excited
hi i'm chance ivey senior technical
designer at epic games
and i'm galen davis producer and
evangelist for quicksilver at epic games
this is reminding me of the
first video we revealed the first look
at what's coming in unreal engine 5
the next generation of our real-time
technology and our demo lumen in the
land of nanite
okay so lumen was the uh basically the
the global elimination technology that
they had
lumen you know lights that make sense
and then nanite was i believe the like
the mesh kind of
decimation whatever they had to reduce
the massive amount of polygons
that they had kind of in their source
assets so like all of the incredibly
detailed meshes that they had how they
would be able to reduce that complexity
so that we could actually render it on
screen in real time
since then the engine team has been
working hard on preparing the tools
and technology for creators around the
world to get their hands on so that they
can explore the new features and provide
us with feedback
now just a few months ago we assembled a
small team of developers to see what
they could build using these new
features
the result is a new practical sample
project called valley of the ancient
today we're excited to give you the very
first hands-on look at some of the new
tools and workflows that we use to build
it
now we've got a lot to get to so let's
get started
xbox series x cool
when setting out to make our demo we
wanted to push the boundaries of what's
oh there's
those shadows are looking so noisy
around the edges
look at that that is interesting anyway
sorry
i'm just pointing out what i'm seeing
and that caught my eye immediately we
wanted to push the boundaries of what's
possible with ub5 today
while targeting next-gen uh the amount
of detail though this is just like
quicksilver mega scans assets piled on
top of this
so much detail i love it here are
sequences running in real time on
playstation 5 and xbox series x
okay playstation 5 as well
i like that kind of turbulent
displacement around the fire
okay welcome to the brand new ui in
unreal engine 5. oh well that ui looks
nice while a lot of the same features
and functionality that you've come to
know when you before are still present
in the new ui
we've added several new systems that put
you at the center of the experience
for example the content browser can now
be accessed like a drawer using hotkeys
allowing you to keep a clean workspace
while still having access to all the
content that you need
we can also collapse and restore editor
tabs to and from the sidebar
maximizing the viewport experience and
you're going to see a lot more of the ui
as we get further into this presentation
that's by the way one thing that i've
kind of felt with unreal engine 4
was that like there was just so much
going on in the ui and i just wanted to
focus on my viewport
and it was just kind of difficult so
this is nice i like that this is so i
can't wait for you to get your hands on
it
that's actually one of the things that i
really want to do with hazel as well is
make sure that you can kind of easily
snap to a view kind of like tab
in photoshop i don't know why i'm
comparing to that but that's something
that i've been using lately
just hitting tab to hide all the tool
panels immediately so you can actually
focus on kind of
what you're actually working on rather
than all the various tools because if
you know the hotkeys
and if you've already got all the meshes
in your scene and maybe you just want to
fly around see how it looks
you don't need any of those tools nearby
yeah one of the main features of unreal
engine 5
is nanite our virtualized micro polygon
geometry system that frees artists to
create as much geometric detail as the
eye can see
virtualized geometry supports orders of
magnitude more triangles without
compromising speed
this i'm super interested in additional
system of mesh lods
handling all detail transitions
seamlessly without any additional setup
one thing i want to quickly point out is
that like the closer we get
to a world in which artists can forget
about technical limitations i think the
further and the better
games are gonna start becoming right
because for anyone working
offline in offline rendering or even
even more offline like
literally with physical media like a
painting it just it becomes so clear how
specific game development is and how
it's so kind of
different than all of those other art
disciplines don't get me wrong if you're
offline rendering like
some kind of feature film and you're you
know you don't need to process anything
in real time
you still very much care about
performance you know you don't want
frames to take
days when they could take hours that's a
big difference for a project
however what i'm more talking about is
you know
when someone sits down to do a painting
they don't worry about
the detail level of stuff in the
background like the mountains you know i
can't put that many flowers there
or i have to make sure that when the
camera is far from those flowers they're
still kind of there they don't
rudely pop in but i can't have too many
of them because then then like the
performance is gonna suffer especially
on like those that kind of lower tier
hardware
and then like but but i want it to look
good from a distance
what do i do and how do i gradually
blend that kind of transition into
being closer to it because now i want
more detail all of these problems are so
specific to
real-time kind of interactive
application rendering
like what games are essentially and
you know these new tools that are
enabling us well supposedly this is i
haven't not heard
that much about this but based on what
they're saying you know no laws no level
of detail systems meaning we have
basically
multiple copies of a mesh or other asset
i guess well i mean for textures it's
called like a mip
chain but in the case of meshes having
multiple copies of it that we can kind
of
you know transition between as we get
closer and we have to worry about that
because we can't afford
that kind of level of detail further
away from the camera
you know having to not worry about that
and for artists to just be able to
create the content as if it was a
painting
and then everything just works
that is that's gonna that's amazing for
the future honestly
in other words nanites lets the artist
create while the engine does the work
yeah exactly visualization the drain you
see individual triangles rendered out as
different colors here in the viewport
and because the geometry is now
virtualized you can feel free to place
assets like these all throughout your
scene to fill up yeah that's incredible
like you know me looking at all this
stuff in the background just
being there and the fact that like if we
go back to that triangle visualization
those are literally like triangles there
they're not like some kind of thing
that's painted in
or like a texture or whatever they're
literally geometry
right each one of these little colors i
imagine represents a completely unique
triangle and a lot of them over there
really are like one or two pixels big
and the fact that like
their nanite system is able to kind of
work out the fact that this triangle
contributes to this pixel
supposedly i'm not sure how it does that
but that's like that's incredible
geometry is now virtualized like this is
the real deal you can place assets like
these all throughout your scene to fill
out a massive player space
using this debug view you can see
individual instances represented by
different colors from swatch to swatch
okay each instance in this environment
contains around one to two million
triangles
providing enough detail for the camera
to roam with complete creative freedom
not sure whether
what they mean like by instance
specifically if they mean like a
separate kind of mesh or a submesh or if
they're talking about like a material
kind of group like a primitive or
something i'm not 100 sure
now they do look like meshes
anti-aliasing solution temporal super
resolution
keeps up with all this new geometric
detail to create sharper
more stable images than before yeah just
looking at this like the anti-aliasing
seems
i mean like it seems perfect i can't
really fault it to be honest
um this looks great i haven't really
quality
really heard of like temporal supers
like super resolution so i guess it's
some kind of super sampling
that they're reducing resolution keeps
up with all this and it's temporal so i
assume it's like frame to frame
more stable images than before with
quality approaching true native 4k
at the cost of 1080p
while highly detailed assets are great
on their own high quality lighting that
realistically reacts to your scene
is what opens the door to more dynamic
worlds and immersive gameplay
lumen is our fully dynamic real-time
global illumination solution that
immediately reacts to scene and light
change
making for more believable experiences
there is some
direct shadow edges again settings
allowing for true physically based
setups for photorealistic environments
the mega skins library has meticulously
calibrated physically based services and
objects in the thousands of assets as of
today and the assets that we're
highlighting
that just reminds me of like tatooine or
something from like attack at the clones
i mean
it's like it looks like a movie and
that's incredible
just how powerful it is to have and just
to be clear the reason
why like it it's sticking out to me
right now
the lighting is good don't get me wrong
but at this level it's not even that
important it's just the
detail it's just the actual meshes the
actual geometry
and the fact that i know that based on
what they've shown us
it's all real it's all real geometry
it's all real
super detailed geometry that is really
exciting
nanite and lumen working in tandem
also thanks to the new sky atmosphere
system it is incredibly simple to
quickly simulate
realistic time of day carefully art
direct volumetric clouds
and make modifications to things like
atmospherics
sun position and fog and for this
example we wanted a fully dynamic scene
no light baking and realistic
interpolation between the different
times of day
yep of course when in development having
access to high quality content that's
easy to use
helps you iterate quickly and saves lots
of time that's why qixel
with quixote now being a part of the
epic games family we've made the full
megaskans library
free and open for all unreal engine
users
bridge our online browser for megascans
assets has historically functioned as a
standalone application
for quickly exporting assets in bulk
directly into the engine
albeit separate from unreal today we're
happy to announce that bridge is now
natively integrated directly into the
engine ui
yeah that's a good move drag and drop
assets directly into your scene
for a more intuitive and connected
experience and simply logging in with
your epic id
gives you immediate access to thousands
of assets to use for free in your unreal
engine projects
we are constantly looking to enhance the
value of the mega scans library
and today we're excited to announce that
we're adding a brand new asset type
called mega assemblies
mega assemblies are the natural next
step for us in removing even more
barriers for artists in crafting their
worlds
by combining existing assets from the
mega scans library
our artists are pre-assembling elements
that can be quickly accessed and
leveraged to populate your scenes
using the moab set let's add an assembly
to our scene
and just like that we were able to
quickly change the composition of this
area in our map
with you live what is all that like a
rubble pulling
this area in our map wow with ue5
we are reimagining what collaboration
looks like for teams and projects of all
sizes
a common challenge when collaborating on
large worlds is deciding how to
structure map content so that everyone
on the team can easily work without
asset contention
while also avoiding painful merge
conflicts
yeah that that's too real i mean having
multiple people
work on a single project is just
incredibly difficult to manage not just
from like a kind of a management point
of view
but if like the actual project files
right unless you end up splitting up the
scene into chunks and having different
artists work on different areas of the
scene which isn't really
ideal working on the same scene file is
a problem that like the industry has
been trying to solve like forever
so so any improvement in that space is
like pretty much always appreciated
easily work without asset contention
while also avoiding painful merge
conflicts
a new system called world partition
makes traditional world-building
workflows obsolete
by changing the way that we think about
map files rather than requiring artists
to build out
map content as a series of streaming
levels world partition allows teams to
think of a single map as one large world
that gets broken down
automatically into many smaller
streamable cells on a grid
these cells can be selectively loaded or
unloaded in the editor to save on edit
time like minecraft
allowing artists to only load up the
sections of the map that they need
on top of that changes to actors in a
world participation interesting contract
at the actor level
not the map level this one file
proactive approach empowers different
team members to work on different actors
in the same map
without having to worry about their
changes getting clobbered and emerge
or having to revert to get someone
else's edits
wow one this approach means you could
have artists one
file per actor that's a lot of files
this is interesting because i was having
a discussion with like some people in
the hazel team recently about
about exactly that like about how um
maybe we should reduce the amount of
files that we create because then that
can be
harder to manage with version control
systems but part of the
part of the appeal of not doing that i
think and doing something like this is
that you
you almost move that whole kind of um i
guess asset like committing and tracking
kind of problem into like another system
to a stable system like
git or perforce or something like that
that you can just kind of
you know manage an external tool in a
way that's obviously been proven to work
for large scale software projects
rather than for example you know having
unreal engine
have to manage all the writing into like
serializing into like certain
files and large files that contain like
all of the actors because that's like
your scene file maybe it contains
all of the actual worlds they're called
an unreal all of the actors inside that
world are in that kind of world file and
then
you know what if someone as an actor
then suddenly i have a merge conflict
potentially and i have to make sure that
when i kind of pull that updated world
file
i can merge all the actors together so i
can still retain both actors having
several files is as simple as just oh
there's another
file on disk now no one cares about that
like that just
works um and that's kind of an
interesting approach as well now this
approach means you could have artists
lighting
set dressing and reworking the landscape
simultaneously
all within the same virtual space yep
that's that's very interesting i might
have to
take down some notes managing this much
content at runtime
typically requires a ton of thought
about how to stream relevant content in
and out to stay inside performance
budgets
yeah fortunately world partition handles
that as well at runtime only the cells
in a user-defined radius from our player
are loaded and as we move
new cells are streamed in while cells no
longer needed are replaced by their
lower resolution
hierarchical level of detail or h-slot
version and since
all projects have different requirements
the cell size and
loading radius are fully configurable to
match each project's content streaming
needs
another feature that comes along with
world partition is data layers
data layers are a way to categorize map
assets and collectively enable or
disable them when you want to alter the
state of the world
working in data layers a separate group
of artists was able to assemble
the imagination with more interactive
elements for our demo
interesting at runtime we can swap
between these two modes
streaming thousands of actors in and out
and enter into the dark world
let's see this in action as we go back
to chance
thanks galen many runtime and
interactive frameworks in unreal engine
are giving significant updates in ue5
one thing we've added for animation is
an experimental new full body ik solver
which is designed to give you better
results with less work
here you can see it in action so invest
kinematics just refers to being able to
position like skeletal bones correctly
depending of course what your definition
of
correct is but essentially feet that
move on the ground you know should react
to the ground
itself if we have a little hill on the
ground we want like the knees to be bent
and that's kind of what an inverse
kinematic solver does it figures out
where to actually place
bones depending on like the surrounding
obstacles or well it's not really it
doesn't have to be specifically with
like ground and walking and other things
it could be
like different constraints that you
place on the bones that
specify that you know my hand has to be
here
so therefore what angle is my elbow bent
at and where is like the rest of my body
and all of those kind of things
as a rig for our player character echo
corrects itself to adjust for variations
on the ground below her
yeah so that's all the terrain all the
rocks stuff like that around 10 times
faster than before
to build and maintain more and that's
actually also something that we saw i
think
in the uh previous kind of uh demo i
guess the first look a year ago
was i think she was like she was
grabbing like walls and stuff that were
around her
so that's also an example of this system
we've also added a new framework called
game feature plugins that will allow you
to build and ship game content in a more
modular way
with game feature plugins numerous core
gameplay features can be built in
parallel with better encapsulation and
finer content organization
game feature plugins allow developers to
add activation instructions to extend
this new ui looks great
register new input actions for players
and interface with other frameworks such
as animation
when we shift it into the dark world we
also activated a new game feature to
give echo a brand new attack ability
all of the assets and logic needed for
the ability including new animations
input controls blueprint code vfx and
audio are contained inside this plugin
and core game classes have no idea that
these assets exist
until we activate it we've also added a
feature called animation motion warping
which allows you to manipulate root
motion animations to adapt them to the
world
echo's fault animation was authored to
the specific dimensions of this rubble
leveraging motion warping we were able
to add notify states in the vault
animation asset that can react to
transform data passed in via blueprints
this allowed us to reuse the same
animation to vault over other assets of
different dimensions
like these pieces of debris by sending
information about their size into the
motion warping system
before triggering the vaulting animation
a blueprint script determines her
rotation
how high up she jumps how far she needs
to move to get to the other side
and where her feet should land yeah
motion warping then adapts the root
motion of the vault animation to match
this data
also for the rift interact enemy i will
point out it definitely does look a
little bit
unnatural like you can kind of see that
slide up that's clearly
more excessive because i assume it's not
going to go in and start modifying like
you know how much weight she's putting
into that jump or anything but i guess
as a as like a quick fix potentially it
would probably work pretty well
we used motion warping to place echo in
the perfect position in order to ensure
her hand would always touch the rift
so on the topic of animation unreal
engine 5 also includes our
in editor rigging tool control rig
meet the ancient a film quality creature
imagined and built by our friends at the
aaron's home
company we partnered with aaron sims and
his group of talented artists to concept
the dark world and to bring it to life
through an enormous mythical adversary
now every single animation for the
ancient was authored wholly in engine by
the aaron sims creative team
using control rig and sequencer our
linear cinematic animation tool
also just to push the boundaries a bit
they even built it out of a collection
of nanite meshes totaling over 50
million triangles attached directly to
the skeleton
control rig was designed to keep artists
close to their creations without having
to bounce back and forth between
software packages
allowing them to quickly iterate all
inside unreal
while imagining the battle between echo
and the ancient we wanted to give the
creature a heavy laser attack that echo
would have to avoid
we needed it to track echo's location in
the arena and fire a slow sweeping blast
towards her
taking advantage of the full body ik
solver mentioned earlier
we were able to influence the direction
and distance the ancient reaches out
during the firing animation
based on where echo is in the scene
let's see the results
here is what the base firing animation
looks like
and here it is again with the full body
ik post process layers enabled
and our info about echo passed into
control rig
with full body ik and control rig yeah
so you can see it's kind of determining
where it can actually place the bones
obviously they can't go infinitely far
because his arm's not infinitely long
but essentially it's just solving you
know for that particular point what do
all of the other
joints are along his arm and potentially
his body look like designers and artists
can now author fully dynamic animations
that react to gameplay without having to
build complex animation state machines
composed of numerous animation assets
yeah i mean that's good you know the
more dynamic you have it the more the
better it's going to look anyway
um you know in a lot of cases it is
better to just try and author assets
you know yourself because certain things
just it's hard to get them to look good
dynamically
but for a lot of other things having
them be dynamic so they're going to
respond to the world and respond to
whatever the player is doing respond to
whatever the terrain is you know stuff
like that
that's important so don't get me wrong
i'm not saying like that you know moving
into like a more dynamic state is better
in general for pretty much every area of
a game engine
another really good example is ai so the
way that i see kind of dynamic ai
is essentially what machine learning is
right instead of actually
you know programming ai to do if you
know if this do that or state machines
or whatever
you're actually giving it the
opportunity to learn and thus it can
actually adjust the behavior based on
what the player what that specific
player might be doing and that's really
powerful
for animation it's the same for lighting
you know being able to dynamically have
scenes change because the player is
shooting out
some kind of i don't know some kind of
like roof or ceiling in a cave that's
going to allow light to go in and then
calculating the global elimination there
that kind of stuff you know that just
means that the world feels way more
alive and less static because
every kind of player experience is in
fact going to be unique
even though it might seem similar to
like other players experiences
you know you know in this case she ran
to different points of the map than
someone else would and therefore that
experience is different and i think
that's
that's one of the coolest things that
exists in video games and why
why they are separate from like movies
and other kind of you know
static types of media i guess because
you define the experience you as the
player define the experience
and having a kind of dynamic world with
all of this kind of dynamics
technology that stuff like really is the
future and it's really exciting to see
stuff like this
in unreal engine 5 we've completely
overhauled the audio engine
centered around metasounds a new asset
type used for every sound effect in our
demo
metasounds bring the power and
flexibility found in material editors to
audio creation
providing fine control that's good
that's good
with full audio synthesis capabilities
and a rich audio function library
metasounds give unprecedented control
over sound effects and runtime
applications
using mouse sounds we built the ancient
laser attack out of a combination of
sound samples and synthesized audio
let's briefly break down how it was set
up using the stereo mixer
let's isolate and play just the
synthesized charge sound
this effect is made by using a handful
of sound wave generators and multiple
modulation widgets
now let's mix back in our sound samples
to hear the final result again
[Music]
all right let's take down the engine
yeah
better audio tools are always good
i will say that smoke effect just
doesn't really seem like it suits
the scene at all i'm not even sure what
it is because it does seem like it's lit
and everything maybe it's just the fact
that it looks like
just a video of like some smoke um
that's just been composited in
but that's probably like the worst
looking thing
in this shot to be honest not that it's
like particularly bad or anything don't
get me wrong everything here looks
amazing but you know i'm just saying
i feel like it's almost maybe the way
that it's blending between the layers or
something like that is weird
now everything we've been showing you in
today's demo focuses on some of the new
features in ue5 but many of your
favorite ue4 features such as niagara
particles and visual effects
chaos physics blueprint visual scripting
and more have also received numerous
updates in unreal engine 5.
plus all your ue4 projects can be
upgraded to ue5
so you won't have to worry about forward
compatibility for what you're working on
now
here at epic we are passionate about
building great tools and new technology
and a big part of our excitement is
being able to bring you
the developer community on the journey
with us so today
we're making an early access build of
unreal engine 5 freely available on the
epic games launcher
and the unreal engine github so you can
explore and test out these tools
yourself to get an early look at what's
coming later in the full release of ue
5.0
also we're releasing the project source
for value of the ancient so you can
check out how we use these features to
build
everything you've seen in today's
demonstration we've got a series of deep
dive conversations i'm gonna have to
take a look at
topics lined up for inside unreal good
our official weekly live stream
where you can hear from the engine dev
team and ask yeah more questions
yeah no that would be good still the
early days of ue5 and you can expect
more news and features to be announced
as we move closer to a production ready
release
targeting early 2022. follow the still
quite a while away
and feel free to download the early
access release of unreal engine 5
and the value of the ancient project
today
thanks everyone for watching and welcome
to early access
okay so i mean my biggest thing at the
moment
is i want to i want to see those deep
dive kind of conversations i
really am interested in more of the
technical details behind this this stuff
is cool
it's not any um i don't know it's not
any different potentially than what
we've seen like a year ago so this was
kind of i guess what i was expecting i
can't say i'm blown away with some
other new feature it is really cool
seeing it kind of more usable and the
fact that this is clearly something that
they're
kind of moving towards a production
ready environment even even if that does
take another like half year or so
um i'm really i'm not so much interested
in the global elimination as
much i have some theories as to how
they're doing that and i don't think
that's
that groundbreaking well to me at least
personally
but i am very excited about this nanite
stuff
being able to handle that massive amount
of data
um and then kind of i guess determine
what's on the screen and not having to
worry about laws and stuff i think
that's
that's really like the most powerful
tool
that that is going to come out of this
so yeah i can't wait to see
more of the technical kind of
information on that in fact i think the
source code is like already available so
maybe i'll have a good read this evening
anyway thank you guys for watching don't
forget to hit the like button if you did
enjoy the video let me know what your
thoughts
were about all of this if there's
something that you want me to talk about
or maybe take a look at then also leave
a comment below
don't forget that i do have a bunch of
various kind of game engines c plus plus
programming
related content on this channel so feel
free to subscribe if you're not already
and check some of that out
as well as follow the development of my
game engine if that's something that you
are interested in
thank you guys for watching i'll see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
you